[Musique]
ce qu'il faut retenir des résultats
sportifs du week-end dans les yvelines
avec michael el nido robond soir un sens
grégory on commence ce tour d'horizon
michael part du football américain les
templiers d'elancourt qui ont débuté
leur saison en deuxième division cette
année encore les élans courtois
accueillez ce samedi à 18h janvier au
complexe sportif l'europe les léopards
de rouen l'occasion pour les joueurs
évinois de montrer les muscles et le
potentiel de l'équipe dans cette
deuxième division
mais le match ne tourne pas en faveur
des élans courtois les joueurs locaux
sont dominés et perdre la partie sur le
score de 22 à 9
l'objectif de montée en fin de saison
n'est pas encore remise en question mais
les joueurs devront trouver rapidement
des automatismes pour emporter à des
victoires on écoute le directeur sportif
il ya un mélange d'anciens et de et de
juniors qui venait qui sont issus des
sections jeunes qui venaient polluer
dans la première saison en senior
donc ça change un peu donc voilà pour
alain temps d'adaptation
voilà à quoi faut qu'après je pense que
quand ils ont repris leur moi qui prends
bien là pour apporter à décrypter les
templiers à joueront leur deuxième match
de la saison le samedi à 1er février
quant au lait contre les myrmidon de
savigny-le-temple toujours à domicile
une équipe qui a remporté son premier
match de la saison contre nantes du
football toujours mais ce qu'on appelle
du soccer à notre côté de l'atlantique
la 2e division de district de football
ce dimanche 19 janvier les jaunes de
plaisir aux sauvé les verts de
rambouillet deux équipes à la lutte pour
le maintien en d2 de district après
quelques minutes d'observation les rangs
boli temps ouvre la marque mais plaisir
revient au score grâce à ce tir en angle
fermé 1 partout un électrochoc pour les
visiteurs qui arrivent à marquer deux
fois avant la mi temps 3 pour
rambouillet en deuxième période plaisir
revient avec de meilleures intentions le
bloc défensif et plus haut c'est grâce
aux coups de pied arrêtés que les
joueurs plaisir avant de revenir au
score deux corners décisifs 3 3 à 15
minutes de la fin du match malgré
quelques situations dangereuses
les deux équipes se séparent sur un
match nul spectaculaire ce résultat
n'arrange aucune des deux équipes dans
la course au maintien à rambouillet
toujours neuvièmes du classement et
plaisir à 10e merci michael haineux pour
ne rien rater un bien sûr de l'actualité
sportive yvelinoise votre émission le
cetud sport après journal et je crois
que vous nous annoncerait une bonne
nouvelle côté golfe je n'en dis pas plus
rendez vous tout à l'heure